The Joe Rogan experience mean he could
if you wanted to,
but he thinks that it complicated.
I feel bad for the Dalai Lama because
Richard Gere always wants to hang out
with.
You can see the Dalai Lama like a
pulling Richard Gere aside one day
going,
hey Richard,
have you ever considered scientology?
You imagine the conversations that Dalai
Lama must have with like Sharon stone
where he's like,
yeah,
I can't believe they chose her either.
I mean,
you look,
yes,
I don't watch a lot of movies,
but you are amazing zing in basic
instinct.
I thought you were amazed and they
didn't think you could pull it off in
the second one.
You pulled it off in the second one.
Did you see this basic instinct too?
It's a horror movie.
It changed.
It changed from an erotic film when
Sharon stone was young too,
like like a panic moment.
Fuck yeah,
I did sign.
I'm a diligent worker when it comes to
watching stupid shit that I might be
able to make fun of.
She's in it right?
But she was like 50 and I'm not joking.
She show anything like that.
But the whole leg thing,
but there's a feeling that you get when
a 50 year old woman who's trying really
hard to be sexy.
Like I don't know if she was directed in
that way.
But when you're 50 you realize by the
time you're 50 you realized it's mostly
all bullshit.
Okay,
what are we doing here?
You know,
if we're gonna fuck,
we're going to talk.
But all this like sultry shift that you
might get away with when you're 20,
it's because you,
you're,
you're a a spell when you're 20.
When a woman is in her young twenties,
she.
The reason why they have this idea of
themselves,
it's so inflated like really beautiful
girls is because they're like magic.
Like you were around him in your,
like your mood changes,
you draw towards them,
you soften your personality to or,
or pick it up or whatever.
You need to get me to like you a little
bit more.
It's like a drug.
It's like a fascinating erotic draw.
But then when they get 50 and they're
still doing the same thing,
then it's like,
oh shit,
what's wrong with her?
Oh fuck.
So when you see her cross her legs,
just like a real moment of panic,
where I would think about me in my
younger days,
if I was in that scenario,
I would.
I would say,
okay,
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
It was that moment with a 50 year old
lady shows you her gapper and then
closes the legs over and they're like,
nope.
I gotta go right now I am going.
That is not the way.
Like a healthy sexually confident 50
year old woman would would fuck you.
I can't believe they just had her do it
again.
That's the lane or two lanes.
It's the unknown.
Necessary.
It was so unnecessary,
you know?
I mean,
what's the Hollywood unnecessary ideas?
Well,
I think it's like someone who's never
done standing up trying to craft a joke
on this is going to work.
You know,
you don't really have a chance to vet
it.
You just have to put it out there as a
movie and hope that people get it in the
first basic jeans to instinct was really
fucking,
you know,
it was well received.
It wasn't the best movie in the world,
but it was kind of fun.
I
took your your interest and she's sexy
as fuck,
man.
Old Sharon stone is sexy as fuck.
That will miss structurally perfect,
beautiful,
beautiful woman and a powerful actress.
But when you 50 keep keep your gap or
shut.